a bit of bad news sad at this point we
got to get it out of the way and the
entrance of again truth truth I do need
to announce that my the scene I shot the
cameo little scene I shot in Avengers
infinity war has been cut oh you were I
didn't know there's nobody more
disappointed than me that's but I mean
that's a huge deal to be one of those
duties and you were you were cut out
well because you know sometimes
obviously you do these little scenes in
in the in the big in the big movie and
then you maybe that Spurs you know take
a Frank a whole new franchise like it's
your whole new really I just wanted the
crowd I wish the people could just seen
this scene we shot it was such a great
scene and you you were playing a kicky
toast anything about it but now there oh
yeah because I'm not spoiling anything
it's been cut out yeah I I played a
character called Captain Japan I'm sorry
you play a character called Captain
Japan
have you not heard of him no I have not
heard of Captain Japan's money because
the scene I shot was with Captain
America he hadn't heard of him either
wait a minute so he's writing it's a
great scene so your captain Japan and I
set the scene I can tell it was a great
I mean you're gonna be sad we hear this
shit's hit the fan right right and all
the Avengers are there you know they're
all doing their you know their work and
you Captain America and Batman boy
wonder and know that those aren't if
anyway go ahead that's fine I'm pretty
sure I saw him okay yeah
Captain America comes around and that's
when he sees me and your captain Japan
and what do you look like you know what
do you it's not almost almost identical
to him but just all red and white mm-hmm
and with the shield light we both we
both have the shield and mines got the
Rising Sun on Japan yeah you don't yeah
exactly and it's this moment where I'm
like I'm here to help and he says who
are you and I say I'm Captain Japan and
he says I've never heard of you and I
say well you would if we were in Japan
I'm really
I'm really big in Japan huh
uh-huh and I said so what's the deal
here he says you're not even you're not
Japanese
I said look no I I was but I was dating
a girl reactor thing we're just dating a
Japanese girl that's it listen I don't
write this stuff they're just you know
and I say look anyway the relationship
didn't work out but the the people they
have really I feel like they've really
embraced me you know and he says do you
speak Japanese and I said no a few words
you know she's still she's captain Japan
and he only knows a few words of
Japanese everybody watch out you know
you knows how to say that get down and
write when you're not sure how this is
gonna go between us there's some
Japanese people come out yeah and
they're like oh captain pan yeah and I I
look at them and I say me not girls girl
what everybody watch out for you keep
your fingers crossed for the for the
franchise yeah it's still I don't think
there's gonna be a friend I'm just being
honest this is just me being honest I
don't doesn't feel like a franchise to
me
you